Donc là c'est moi devant le temple 4,
là, c'est moi dans le temple 6
Ici c'est moi devant le temple 1...
Y'en a combien des temples ?
Y'en a 17.
Ah, d'accord.
Là c'est moi devant le temple 6...
Non, temple 5, pardon !
Ok, c'est super intéressant,
c'est des sites touristiques
incontournables en amérique centrale
mais tu sais pour les archéologues c'est
plus intéressant d'imaginer
qu'un temple maya c'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg
et que il y a bien plus à apprendre
de ce qu'on ne voit pas.
Mais tu sais que j'ai rencontré des chercheurs
qui ont fait des découvertes
de folie sur les Mayas
juste en étudiant la forêt tropicale.
2018 marque
un tournant dans la connaissance
de la civilisation maya.
Une collaboration internationale de scientifiques
a entrepris de cartographier
le relief du sol
sur plus de 2000 kilomètres carrés en zone maya,
dans ce qu'on appelle les basses terres centrales
entre le Guatémala, le Mexique
et le Belize.
Le quoi ?
Le Bélize.
Si, si,  c'est un pays.
D'ailleurs on devrait
en parler plus souvent,
c'est vraiment bien le Bélize.
Et pour étudier une
telle zone recouverte de forêts denses
les scientifiques ont recours à la
technologie lidar.
Clotilde, tu peux m'aider à expliquer ce que c'est le lidar?
Le lidar est une technique d'imagerie
qui permet d'enregistrer les
microreliefs du sol.
Quand on n'a pas accès directement aux vestiges,
qu'ils sont indétectables par photos aériennes,
comme c'est le cas pour la plupart des
sites mayas recouverts par la végétation,
et bien le lidar peut être une solution.
Concrètement c'est un laser embarqué
dans un avion ou un drone qui survole la
forêt.
Ainsi on peut modéliser à partir
d'un nuage de points lidar 3d du sol,
des sites archéologiques et leur environnement.
En somme le lidar qui est l'acronyme pour ...
fait partie des...
Oui, bon, ça va!
fait partie des diverses techniques employées
par l'archéologie environnementale et la géoarchéologie.
Mais je vous parle un peu
plus de ça dans un épisode
qui vous attend sur ma chaîne.
Douze zones ont été
cartographiées par lidar.
Et à partir de ces modèles numériques de terrain,
une équipe scientifique franco guatémaltèque
s'est intéressée plus particulièrement
aux sites mayas de Naachtun.
A tes souhaits !
Merci.
Et ça donne ça :
Et là, que n'ont ils pas découvert ?
Des cités mayas englouties !
Non c'est pas vrai.
Mais ils ont réussi à identifier tout un
tas de constructions
qui étaient invisibles jusqu'à présent.
Et ce qui est surprenant, c'est que le peuplement
est beaucoup plus dense que ce que l'on
pensait.
Sur les 135 kilomètres carrés de la zone de Naachtun,
on retrouve les vestiges de plus de douze mille habitations.
Soit une densité de population
de l'ordre de celle de Salon de Provence
ou de Nogent le Rotrou.
Le Ro...quoi ?
Le Rotrou.
C'est une ville.
D'ailleurs on n'en parle pas assez.
Ca ne vous paraît peut-être pas énorme,
mais jusqu'ici les chercheurs
pensaient que la population Maya
était regroupée dans des cités très
densément peuplées
comme celle que nous visitons aujourd'hui,
et dans quelques zones résidentielles attenantes.
Le reste des terres étaient de grands
champs cultivés en agriculture
peu intensive, et occupés par une population paysanne
plutôt éparse.
En réalité les images Lidar
montrent une forte densité de la population
sur tout le territoire de Naachtun.
On voit ici de nombreuses habitations
y compris dans les zones éloignées du centre de la cité,
que l'on pensait jusque-là dédiée simplement  à l'agriculture.
Seules les zones inondables - les barõs -
ne semblent pas occupées.
Vous imaginez à quel
point cette découverte change notre
vision de la civilisation maya.
On pensait avoir affaire aux châteaux de la Loire,
et on se retrouve face aux
banlieues pavillonnaires du Val de Loire.
Mais attention ces structures n'ont pas
forcément été utilisées toutes en même temps.
Oui. Petit rappel : la civilisation
Maya se développe sur trois millénaires.
Résultat, ce que vous voyez sur ses
relevés n'est pas toujours de la même époque.
Les scientifiques se sont alors intéressés
aux vestiges de l'exploitation des terrains
et des ressources en eau.
Fallait bien les nourrir !
En analysant les reliefs,
ils ont découvert dans les secteurs de
collines plus de 19000
terrasses agricoles réparties dans toute la zone habitée.
Et dans les marais plus de 5400
canaux d'irrigation et de drainage,
près de 900 réservoirs,
sans compter des champs,
des bassins et des digues.
Les habitants de Naachtun exploitaient donc les terres
de façon intensive et avaient en plus
développé un système de gestion de l'eau
leur permettant de traverser les redoutables et aléatoires saisons sèches .
Enfin, les chercheurs ont identifié de
longues chaussées surélevées,
des routes qui relient les cités principales entre elles,
et qui constituent un maillage dense
qui quadrille la zone sur plus de 60
kilomètres de long.
L'analyse des modèles numériques de terrain
obtenus grâce au lidar
permet donc d'avoir une vision
des paysages et de la société maya dans les basses terres
très différente de celle de l'archéologie classique.
En fait c'est un peu un leurre de croire
que toute la vie tourne autour des
temples,
alors que franchement le paysan maya
après sa journée de boulot,
il rentrait direct dans son pavillon de
banlieue.
Ouais c'est vrai.
Les prochaines campagnes de fouilles
permettront de dater plus précisément
l'occupation de Naachtun,
et de compléter ce nouveau modèle
d'urbanisme et de gestion
environnementale du territoire maya.
Tu sais, il faut pas toujours chercher le
savoir dans les temples
il est parfois juste devant son champ.
C'est de qui cette citation ?
Ben c'est de moi.
Et si ce sujet vous a intéressé,
n'hésitez pas à aller voir l'épisode
sur la chaîne de Clotilde : Passé Sauvage.
Et abonnez-vous ...
aux deux chaînes !